- Regardless if you're
trying to raise money
for a non-profit, if you're
trying to run for mayor,
if you're trying to sell socks
or change the perception of a brand,
regardless of what you're all doing here,
all of us are trading attention.
(materials clattering)
(audience laughing)
Thank you, London, I'll see you guys!
(funky music)
All right, I'm gonna start.
(indistinct chattering)
First of all, I wanna thank
everybody for coming out.
It's great to see a
bunch of familiar faces
and a bunch of new faces.
The format here is I'm
gonna maybe kick it off
for 10 or 15 minutes,
maybe a little kind of
how I see things, and then I'm gonna have
an incredible individual join me
to interview a little fireside chat
and I'll let her introduce
herself in a little bit,
and that will go for what?
15, 20 minutes, you think?
- [Anne-Marie] 15, 20 minutes
then we'll take some questions--
- Yeah, I mean ultimately if
you have any context for me,
I'm obsessed with as much Q&A as possible
and so I think that's, you know,
I'm just appreciative of your time
and I'm sure there's many things
you could be doing tonight.
And so for you to come out,
it means a lot to me obviously.
For me personally, this is a fun night.
As I watch Vayner as a whole gain momentum
in this incredible city
in this part of the world,
it's exciting to me.
We're now a couple of years in.
Are we three years in, Eric, or two?
Are we three years into London now?
- [Eric] Two.
- Two, okay, cool.
(audience chuckling)
We're starting to make some noise here
and for me, I just really
enjoy this market quite a bit.
I'm excited to schlep out
here every six weeks or so,
maybe going forward as
this continues to grow.
And more importantly,
both on the corporate side
and the entrepreneurial side,
there's just a lot of great
energy and a lot of opportunity
in the marketplace.
And a lot of the stuff that I spiel,
as you guys probably know,
is very US-centric by nature.
But what's great about
a market like the UK
or most of Europe for that
matter outside of Russia
is that a lot of things
around influence or marketing
or voice, Facebook or many other things
that I'm passionate about
actually are even a better deal
in this market because
of the supply and demand
of how many people are doing it
and how far along the mark it is.
And so I've always found it
kind of interesting and fun
that a lot of the stuff that
I'm most passionate about
actually over indexes
outside of the market
outside of mainland China
and Russia specifically
because they are built on the back
of the Googles and Facebooks
and Instagrams of the world.
So all right, so where do I wanna start?
I think when I speak I
try to bring as much value
for the net audience, and
I think the biggest thing
that I'd like to share first is
I'm fascinated by people's
inability to understand
how much abundance and
opportunity there is in the system
regardless of what anybody is doing here,
and I've got a good sense of the most
corporate of corporate to the most
entrepreneurial of
entrepreneurial starting off.
You know, I think it's really fun for me
when I watch mainstream media or society
decide to paint one narrative
completely at the face of reality,
aka, this is the greatest
moment to be alive.
There's more opportunity,
there's more advancements.
No shit, there's a billion things wrong,
there always will be,
it's how we're wired,
but for me, at its top line framework,
what continues to keep me
up at night in a good way
is my god, there's so much opportunity.
This Internet thing is a
lot bigger than I think
all of us are really settling into,
including people that try
to spend all their time
figuring it out like me.
And so first and foremost,
I really wanna talk tonight
in a macro about offense.
You know, there's so much abundance,
there's nobody, there's not
a company or person on earth.
That success is coming out of your pocket.
And so once you actually
understand that truth,
you spend very little time on defense
and worrying about anybody else
and you start spending all your time
on the one thing everyone
in here should be
spending their time on,
regardless if you're trying
to raise money for a non-profit,
if you're trying to run for mayor,
if you're trying to sell socks
or change the perception of a brand,
regardless of what you're all doing here,
all of us are trading attention.
(materials clattering)
(audience laughing)
Thank you London, I'll see you guys!
I think that's one way to get attention.
That was very well played.
Sound is definitely, audio
is something I'm into.
(audience laughing)
It's attention, and
attention is underpriced
if you know where to look for it
and it's just a remarkable
time for all of us.
There's so much you can do.
And I love that the Internet
gets to be the middle, not a person.
You have to understand
why so much is happening
socially in our society.
The establishment has lost control.
The Internet is the middleman
of information, the end.
And so now what's happening
is we have to face
all our shortcomings around
race and sexism and nationalism
and all the things we will do,
but I think in a 100-year window,
this is gonna be the greatest thing.
Because once we start
understanding each other
hell of a lot better, and
once thematics like empathy
and compassion actually
become differentiators
for your own selfish wants and needs,
we will all be forced
into a far better place
because the old way of
media and communicating
allowed for shadows which
created all these shortcomings.
So everybody can sit here and tell me
everything they're worried
about socially or business-wise,
and I will tell you you
should be optimistic
because these are the beginning stages
of a far better place for all of us.
Now the question becomes
what are your selfish needs
over the next decade that make you upset
about the current state of things?
And that's what you have to realize.
I am sure, because I know how good she is,
we'll get into details
around digital trends
and I can't wait.
Wherever you wanna go
with Q&A, I'm thrilled.
You have to understand
the game you're playing.
And the game you're playing
is, number one, this,
outside of diseases
and terrible accidents,
everybody here is gonna live
a fuckload longer than they think.
If you look at the macro developments,
it's just scary, you just are.
And so all of a sudden, when
I look around this room,
what breaks my heart is that
42-year-olds don't realize
that it's early.
I don't know what else to say.
It's a heartbreaking
thing for me to know that
88% of them are gonna
live another 50 years
and they've basically decided
that they missed their chance.
That's completely not practical
and it's buying into propaganda,
no different than, I'll use
something that's in society,
I think terrorism is a
super fascinating thing.
If it was real, a car the size of a truck
would run into people in
London, Paris, New York
every day of the week because
it's 100% unstoppable.
The fear of it is far
greater than its reality.
And so I think about age that way.
We live in a world now
where there's so much
extreme success for the youth
that a lot of us who are
over 40 didn't grow up with,
you couldn't get that
big and win that well
because the Internet didn't exist
and you had to go through
the incumbents to get there.
So what happens is you
look at a 27-year-old
that seemingly has their
together or winning
and as a 42-year-old you
might say fuck, I fucked up.
Meanwhile, you have your
whole life in front of you.
And so I am unbelievably,
unbelievably moved by things
in a sad way, like the Kate
Spade news yesterday, right?
Like, I'm really into
like the mental thing
and like this is the operating system.
And so you know, probably
some of you are aware of this,
for a long, long time,
a lot of the motivational part of me
was something I wasn't willing
to express in public, right?
I didn't wanna be, I
still don't want to be
a motivational speaker.
I have no interest in that
whatsoever, I really don't.
I recognize I have motivational tendencies
and it's because I'm optimistic.
I'm not motivational, I'm just optimistic
because the math and data is in my favor.
We're healthier, we're
better, there's less bad.
We've got eyes on bad, and
we should because that's how
you smoke out bad.
I'm thrilled.
I think it's the best right now.
And no matter what your
selfish wants and needs are
as a person, you've
never had a better chance
to make it happen than right now.
Your grandparents had
shit compared to this.
I love when everybody runs
all these articles right now
about like Millennials have it worse
than a generation before,
sure if you decided to collect
$200,000 in debt in college
and go work in a corporation.
I understand.
But theoretically, that's not the truth.
That is your circumstance, that's the data
because everybody was
taught to be a student
and go play in the system.
It doesn't mean that it has
never been more practical
for you to get out of that
context and do your thing
in the abundance of opportunity.
You may have been trained,
grew up in a household,
been so marketed to, to
believe this is the only way
you can go, but the second
you're willing to look
and see this, you know what I think about,
you know that picture
where they have that thing
where like you look at it
and you're supposed to say
is it two people kissing
or a glass of champagne?
You know what I'm talking about, right?
You guys have seen that shit, right?
I don't know what the fuck that's called,
but I gotta figure it out for
the purpose of my analogy.
It's basically how I think I live life.
I just think everybody sees it one way,
and for whatever reason,
parenting, circumstance, DNA,
I've always seen it the other way
and it's never been more
crystal clear for me
than it is right now,
which is it is ridiculous
opportunity out there, and I
highly recommend you get yours.
And when I say that, look,
actually, as a counteract to the energy
you might think I'm putting out,
I think most people aren't entrepreneurs.
I think one of the great
mistakes that are happening
in our society right now is everybody
wants to be an entrepreneur
because it's not a pedestal now.
Like I don't know, it's
crazy to me to watch
like rappers and athletes
all think I'm cool
because they wanna be,
like entrepreneurs is having its moment.
The problem is that's a talent.
Like, if you do not have the stomach
for wearing scarlet
letters, you will lose.
And so this is not about
go be an entrepreneur
or dream or fucking the secret,
dream it and it'll be true.
This is practical shit.
Is if you actually understand
what makes you tick,
which could be being a
number six at a company
that you believe in,
which could be a million different things,
if you can deploy self-awareness
and you deploy effort
against that self-awareness,
I promise you, the history books will say
that us during this time
had the most opportunity
because the fundamental
society is being shifted
on the back of this technology.
And that's without
anticipating what Blockchain
is actually gonna do
and many other things that are happening.
So I guess my opening rant
is I'm optimistic as fuck,
I hope you are as too.
And if you're not, you
need to really start
asking yourself what's going on.
Because if you're not winning
in happiness right now,
then you've got a real problem
because this last 10 years
of global economic growth
won't last forever, and all
this abundance will shrink.
And if you don't grab your land now,
they'll be less to grab when
we have to pay the piper
for all the bullshit
other people are doing.
And so I really, really encourage you
to think about yourself
in a much longer term
and a much more self-awaring way,
and I just genuinely believe a lot of good
will come of that.
And that, I wish you way
more than all the stuff
that I'm excited to talk about,
which is the micro of execution
within these platforms
that create this macro thesis.
So thanks for being here.
(applause)
Why don't you introduce yourself?
- Thank you, Gary, my
name is Anne-Marie Tomchak
and I'm the UK editor for Mashable,
which is a site that covers
(lone woman cheers)
a lot of technology--
- Good shit.
- That's Jenny,
my social media editor.
Thank you, Jenny.
(laughs)
And Gary and I have
actually had some chats
for my coverage at Mashable
about topics like voice AI,
which is something we can
get into if you'd like,
but there's lots of others
areas we wanna get into as well.
And you've actually picked up on something
that's been on my mind and
on the Mashable team's mind
a lot recently, which is this idea
of compassionate technology and empathy,
and I noticed like in your Instagram feed
and all the quotes you
used, you used the words
kindness and caring and compassion.
And it seems to me that there's
been something recognized
along the way very, very recently
amongst the large tech companies
about their responsibility
towards fostering
a more compassionate use of technology.
If you look at Apple for example,
they're devising ways to make
their iPhone less addictive.
Instagram, looking at ways in which
users can monitor the amount of time
they spend scrolling, i.e.,
potentially wasting time.
So I'd actually love
your take on this issue
because sometimes I feel like you give
mixed messages about technology,
I hope you don't mind me saying that,
(Gary stutters)
and the reason is
- Please go ahead.
(audience laughing)
- The reason I say that is
because you're very much
an advocate of technology.
- Yes.
- Right?
But there are clearly
negative side effects too that as well.
So how do you address those
negative side effects,
those negative emotions that people feel
when they're on Instagram
and they feel the toxicity
of the platform?
How do you manage to make
it work for yourself?
What can you teach others?
- Well, I think that's a fair observation
because I would argue that my strength
is in my contradictions
and being able to hold
different views at the same time.
I also think that in our
interactions with each other,
you and others are taking
too far of a pessimistic view
and we're fear-mongering
technology a little bit too much
on this thesis.
My question is what's the alternative?
To me, we cannot have a
conversation of addiction
of an Instagram feed
without asking the question,
those three and a half hours
that Susan in Manchester
is spending in the feed that
we are so critiquing over here
on our pedestals, what was she doing
with those three and a
half hours otherwise?
I think we've long forgotten
about what's the ROI
of a girl in her room
on her own phone line
talking to her three friends
for six and a half hours?
I think we've long forgot about,
in those same three and a half hours,
I love how people think
going through Vogue
and going through E magazine
and Sports Illustrated
for three hours in an
afternoon over a cup of coffee
while it's raining is any different
than the exact same thing that
you're doing on Instagram,
which is images on a piece of paper.
So a couple of things, number one, yes.
And that's why I love recording everything
because some of these
things will play out.
Net-net, do I believe
the addictions to phones,
open platforms, social networks,
all these things that
have become the foundation
of communication in our society,
do I believe that that is better
than allowing Rupert
Murdoch, Red Summerstone
and four other men in their 70s
to control all the thoughts
we think through media
and their editing?
Yes I do.
Do I think that sexism and racism
and a lot of other human shortcomings
are a product of that system?
I sure do.
So if you ask me about the alternative
of Instagram and the iPhone and Facebook
versus CBS and the BBC and
Sky and the London Times,
I will choose what we have now.
- Okay, so let me ask you
about that under the question
because one of the key things
or one of the key reasons why
these devices area so
addictive is because of
for example, the type of hormones
you release in your brain.
The dopamine levels you get
when you get all those likes,
the cortisol levels when you see
the red notification
pop up on your screen.
So there's something
happening here to our brains
and there's engagement happening
with a certain community
that wasn't happening when
you're just watching a TV screen
or if you're just flicking through a book.
You've got this whole other world--
- Be careful, be careful.
You're making an assumption
that people aren't speaking to.
They are happening.
- The engagement on
digital platforms in a way
that where a television
is broadcasting out to you
but you're not necessarily
talking back to it.
- Yes, but if you look
at the biggest habits,
we're not talking back to a lot
of those things either, right?
Like, you're making an
assumption that we are--
- I guess what I'm saying is the dynamics
are a bit different.
- Well, here's the question.
Do I rather have the masses be the ones
that fuck with your psychology?
Or do I wanna leave that to
your mother and your aunt
and your coworker?
I'm being serious here, guys.
Look, I think about this shit a lot.
I think we're having
very lazy conversations
and defaulting into what we always do
in the same way that big companies
scrutinize Facebook and Google
but accept television commercials.
I think we're accepting that these devices
are doing something without recognizing,
do I think it's better for
a lot of people in this room
to consume my content over
the pessimistic content
that their mother would be
giving them over the phone
if this didn't exist?
Yes I do.
- Okay, so here's
another question for you.
- Sure.
- Recently, on the 25th of May,
we brought in new data
protection rules, GDPR,
here in Europe.
- I've heard.
(audience laughing)
- Which leads me to ask you
a question about regulation,
guys like broadcasters are regulated here.
We have off com, we have
advertising status and associations
and the Internet, in many ways,
feels like a wild wild west
which provides so much opportunity,
that opportunity you talk about,
but it also it poses the question
about how much regulation it needed.
And I wonder what your thoughts are
on whether something like
GDPR is needed in the US.
- Well look, I think it's a good question.
My natural reaction is
of course Europe did
over-regulation, right?
I think it's been the great shortcoming
of Europe as a whole, and I
think the US will follow suit
because every leader in the free world
always starts to get soft over time
in a lot of ways correctly and
a lot of ways not correctly.
I think it will happen in the US
because I think the incumbent companies
like Facebook and Google will realize
that's an advantage to
them, not a disadvantage,
so they will work with Congress
to get these rules because
it will make the incumbents
of progress have a much
harder time to capitalize.
Look, forget about free market.
This is not about being a capitalist
or things of that nature.
I, Gary, believe the
number one underrated thing
in the universe is the human being.
I am flabbergasted by our inability
to understand how special we are.
This was back to the point
I made about terrorism
because if we had so many bad
people, that would happen.
I wanna remind everybody
that the free world
could be blown up at any moment
now for the last 70 years.
We are unbelievably, as an animal, good.
Like unbelievably.
It's just the truth.
And so I think we get very
fancy and sit in ivory towers
that 87 people think that
they should be regulating us
on everything at all times,
and I think at times it gets heavy-handed.
I think the human is very good
at regulating him or herself.
But at the same token, I'm
super not overly emotional
like if we're talking about
like free markets versus not,
I'm not devastated by it.
To me, if everyone's
playing by the same rules,
almost every game is interesting to me
as long as everyone's
playing by the same rules.
I think people play by the
same rules when it's open,
not when it's closed.
And I think it's probably at some level,
a version of it inevitable in the US
because it actually helps
the incumbent big companies,
not the end user.
- I'd love to ask you a bit more about
your views on the human race
because there is this big
conversation going on now
about artificial intelligence,
about robots coming to take us over
and are super intelligent,
eventually going to usurp the human race.
And there are some very, very
credible voices out there
that believe these things.
You and I touched on this
before in our conversations.
What's your viewpoint on that now?
- Yeah, I think there's
a really logical path
to the robots killing us.
(audience laughing)
I mean it, like I don't know,
if we were a bunch of fucking dinosaurs
sitting around one day,
we would have laughed
at the humans winning this game too.
I mean, is it so far-fetched?
I don't think so.
I think we're starting to see shit.
I'll tell you, that robot
that isn't gonna be able
to be detected by Blu-ray,
that shit scared me.
I'm like, that makes sense.
Like I don't know, I
try to stay in my lane.
A lot of the stuff I'll
talk about tonight,
I know my shit, I feel compassionate.
I'm fully guessing here now,
but I will definitely say
I'm definitely not willing
to say no chance never.
- Okay, okay, that's good for thought.
Right, let's talk about stuff
that you really do know about.
Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat, Twitter,
all the social platforms, right?
- Yes.
- Everyone wants to know,
myself included as part of a publisher,
is how would you use this
as a key marketing tool
or a key tool to reach an audience?
And there's so many changes going on now,
with Facebook in particular,
all of the various
different controversies
that have happened with it,
Cambridge Analytica data crisis,
the algorithm changing, the
amount of control they have,
all that stuff, there's a
major power struggle going on.
I'd love to know your
thoughts on where it's at,
where should people be
focusing their energies on,
or is it a case of like trying to have
a little finger in every little pie?
- The way I think about
this is very simple.
I think that the Internet
is the first layer
of our society, period.
And then I think there's been
seven to 10 companies globally
that have been able to get so big,
they're a layer themselves
on top of that layer,
a tollbooth per se, a Facebook,
an Apple, a Tencent, right?
And then it's our jobs, whether
it's Mashable or Gary Vee,
to be the best next
layer by using the layer
that was built on top of
the Internet layer to,
I think, how do I fuck Facebook
before it fucks me, right?
That's how I think.
And I think what publishers
did extremely poorly
in the last half decade is they loved
what Facebook was doing
for them in the short term
and they gave up all
their equity and they got,
and let's call it what it is,
awfully lazy and complacent
and allowed Facebook and other platforms
to get the equity from them
because they didn't reinforce their email,
they didn't reinforce
their first party data,
they didn't reinforce their thing.
So I think you have two camps.
You have the camps that
are like fuck social,
it's this terrible enemy,
and I'm all about first party data
and I have an email
service and text message
and I'm fucking more old-school quant,
you know, DR Gaillard
dude from the 2003-4 era,
fuck all this world, right?
And then you have a
different regime that like
loves all this stuff.
I kind of sit back to your point in both.
I love having first in
line and having that data.
I love having an email list,
I love having a website.
But I also love dominating
on Facebook and LinkedIn
and Snapchat and Instagram
because that's where
the attention is, right?
And anybody that creates
friction for the user
is doing it and giving
up some of the value.
At the same token, you need to
create some of that friction
because if you let everything
play out on that platform,
you become commoditized.
Facebook is the number
one underpriced platform
in our society.
Facebook and Instagram together
can do enough damage for
everybody's ambitions here
for quite a while in my opinion.
And if you are not a great you know,
practitioner of the analytics,
the paid media capabilities
and most importantly,
the creative variable
that makes you successful
in these platforms, you are either leaving
an enormous amount of upside on the table
or you are starting to do the process
that is gonna lead to your demise
in any kind of relevance or growth
of your business or ambitions.
- Can I ask a question on
behalf of entrepreneurs
(crosstalk) developing
apps and other features.
This week at WWDC,
Apple announced a lot of new features
that are gonna come in iOS 12.
- Group chat FaceTime?
- Yeah, there's a lot of things
that are extremely familiar in there.
Like things that look like
Prisma or Snapchat or--
- Houseparty.
- The list goes on.
- Because features are features.
- Yeah, they're features.
- Does anybody cry when Gucci
makes a fucking cool jacket
and then every fucking fashion house
has their version of it the next day?
Like, did anybody notice that the Yeezys
changed every sneaker style?
Like, this notion that it's bad in digital
but it goes on everywhere in the world,
in every category, features are features.
- If you can't beat them,
join them, is my question.
Is that like what we're dealing with here?
- They're not joining,
they're not joining--
(crosstalk)
- Away from the tech companies.
- They're not joining shit.
They're not joining
them, they're taking it.
- That's my question.
So how do the people who
are not part of Apple,
not part of Google, not
part of the major companies
who are basically like
more or less adopting
other people's ideas and innovations,
how do they continue to innovate
against this massive tidal wave?
- By recognizing that
all the future frontiers
where this plays out are
being built right now.
So cool, you can't innovate on a feature
in a social network, but
I don't see you crying
that nobody can innovate and search
because Google's been the incumbent now
for fucking 15 years, right?
Maybe what you should do is realize social
might be gone now, and let
me go figure out voice or AR
or machine learning or Blockchain.
There's always a next platform.
- Yeah, there's load I
wanna ask you on voice.
- And let's, I mean look, we're here,
I'm not going anywhere.
But this is important, this is important.
I don't understand why we keep doing this.
We accept the past, we
criticize the current.
We criticize Facebook for this,
but nobody's criticizing Google
did the same thing on search
which is why you're not on the,
nobody cried for Yahoo.
(audience chuckling)
Right?
- Or MySpace.
- Right?
So to me, this is the greatness
of what Bezos or Zuckerberg are doing,
they continue to innovate.
Why don't we look at the fact
that they continue to innovate, right?
Nobody got mad at NBC for
teaming up with Microsoft
to create MSNBC on cable.
Nobody got mad at like
a real estate tycoon,
she went out and bought
every good neighborhood
for her 30-year run, she innovated.
Like, why don't we actually look at Google
and other companies like IBM
and others and GE and SAP.
Why the fuck was Venmo created by two kids
and not by the Royal Bank of Scotland?
Guys, we are looking
at this the wrong way.
We're demonizing people that are doing
without questioning what
the incumbents were doing
with all their fucking money.
- Right, so I've asked you
quite a few negative questions,
but it's in my DNA as a
journalist and I had to do that.
- I get it.
- So let's actually talk
of some of the more positive things.
I'd love to get your thoughts
on how spaces like Instagram
are driving popular culture and you know,
what specific areas do you see Instagram
being a complete hotbed for
innovation in certain cultural--
- By being, I mean, Instagram is culture.
Like, if you don't understand that,
like, all of the cultural plays,
like if you're not winning on Instagram
from a cool or culture standpoint,
whether you're on hip-hop
or eSports or fashion
or anything, music,
anything that we would say
is popular culture, you are losing.
If you are not winning on
Instagram, you are losing.
And it's funny, it's
very fascinating to me,
I'm fascinated that people think
anything ever stands still.
I like when people are like
not winning on Instagram,
they think they're maintaining their spot.
You are either declining,
or you are growing
at every second.
And so my big fear is that people think
well, I'm okay, my brand
is still doing well,
I'm still doing well.
Nuh-uh, nuh-uh.
If you are not winning on Instagram
and you are in pop culture,
fashion, music, eSports,
other things, comedy, you're in trouble.
- What about television?
The reason I ask you this
is that there's a show
here in the UK that
just started this week,
it's been on for many seasons...
(audience laughing)
You know my next words?
It's called Love Island.
- Love Island.
(audience chuckling)
- I think it's very much influenced
by that Instagram generation.
Have you watched it?
- Nope.
- Awww.
(audience groans)
- But it sounds phenomenal.
I'm desperately interested.
- It's basically a social
and cultural phenomenon
and everyone's having amazing
conversations around it,
they're buying things
on the Love Island app,
they wanna have the bikinis
that they're wearing,
basically people pair up,
it's like the Bachelorette
meets the Big Brother house.
- Makes sense.
(audience chuckling)
- Okay, so we'll hear your thoughts
on Love Island another time once--
- No, but Love Island's
been around for a long time.
- Yeah, but it's something bigger now.
- Of course, but it's been around forever.
We love social.
Guys, there's a reason traffic happens
when there's a car accident.
You're fucking nosey.
(audience laughing)
The reason I think I will ultimately have
a good business career
is because shit's basic
and comes intuitive to me,
and I've never complicated it
with over educating myself
or thinking I'm fancy.
Shit's basic.
We love social experiments,
we like attractive people.
Like, there's not a whole
lot of complicated shit
going on here, right?
- Right, rapid fire round.
What game are you playing right now?
- None.
What song are you listening to right now?
- I Remember by Tee Grizzley.
- The show you're watching?,
- None.
- What wine are you
drinking at the moment?
- All of them.
(audience laughing)
- What team are you
supporting, because I noticed
you were talking about soccer
on our Twitter recently.
- This is probably the most fun thing
happening in my life right now,
which is I wanna pick
a proper football team.
And so Tottenham is
the first jersey I wore
because they haven't won
in 40 or so years, right?
The biggest debate I'm making now is
I'm basically down to
the finals in my head
and then I'll pick the team,
which is the following:
if they're in the Premier League,
then they can't have won
in the last 25 years.
So who's still in there?
The bigger question I wanna ask myself
is do I wanna go all the
way down to the third league
and try to run the whole
thing of the whole process
all the way up, which is kind
of where I think I wanna go.
- Snapchat or Instagram?
- Instagram.
- Facebook or Twitter?
- Facebook.
- Uber or Lyft?
- Uber.
- French chardonnay or
Californian chardonnay?
- French chardonnay.
- Oh, interesting.
- What is the most surprising
thing about you, Gary?
- I think the most
surprising thing about me,
my intuition is the most
surprising thing about me
is I don't think people realize
how deeply committed I am
to the propaganda that I spit.
- Wow, there's a lot to unpack there.
(audience laughing)
- I'll unpack it for a second.
I get high on my own supply.
I have no interest in letting
anybody have leverage over me.
So in a world where all my employees
have access to my email, my DMs,
where DRock fucking
films me in every move,
I have to, by virtue of what
I've decided my ambitions are,
play a game of life of
like you see what you get
at a level that I think is more extreme.
I am fascinated by people
that are fans like DRock
that eventually get to
work very close with me.
Even if they've consumed me
every day for four years,
within week one of them working for me,
they will inevitably
come to me, be like fuck,
it really is really like this, huh?
So I think humans, for
protection purposes,
create a level of cynicism.
I'm pushing it so hard and kind
of going at it a certain way
that I have empathy
that people create that,
but I think the thing that
would be most surprising,
I'm so unbelievably not driven by money,
yet I have, back to contradictions,
I am like stunningly not driven by money
but I wanna buy a multi-billion
dollar sports organization.
I read all of your comments,
yet I actually don't give a fuck
what you have to say about
me and play within my own.
So it's like--
- Care but you don't care--
- What do you think, DRock?
I think you have a better
answer than I have.
What's your take?
What's the most surprising thing about me?
(distant indistinct muttering)
- What did he say?
- [Audience] It is what it is.
- You are what you are.
- It is what it is.
Like, I think I'm so
obsessed with my legacy,
and I think that's selfish,
that I don't think most
people 100% live their life
based on their legacy.
And I'm very close.
I don't know if I'm a
hundred, but like fuck,
I really want it, I want it.
And I think it's selfish and not like,
I don't think it's special.
I just think it's the way I was wired
and so that's what I think it is.
- I've got loads of questions that people
have sent in to me on
Twitter and on my Instagram,
one of which was a challenge
asking me to arm wrestle you.
(laughs)
- I will break your face.
(audience laughing)
- My reply back was,
I think he's gonna be too much of a gent
to accept the challenge--
- No (mumbles).
(audience laughing)
Nope, got that one wrong.
I'll take any win I can get anywhere.
There were some brand questions on Twitter
but I'd love to just
go into the floor first
and we'll try then to get
(crosstalk) at the end
if we have time.
So do any of you have any
questions you'd like to ask Gary?
- And guys, go high or
low, like go selfish.
We're here, right?
- Yeah, this is a really
great Internet opportunity.
- What's your name?
- Nol.
(distant indistinct muttering)
- They won't.
But they're smart, and they're
milking the living shit.
There's tons more.
Lola, there's hundreds.
The amount of brands
that are going from zero
to 10 million in sales
on influencers in Facebook
and YouTube is like...
(snaps)
That's why I sit here and I'm
like this isn't propaganda
or what's coming.
This is real life.
I mean, do you know how
many people just play
Chinese supply chain, Amazon arbitrage
and are doing two million a year?
Like people don't understand,
this is my opening rant to you
which is like are you happy?
Because if you're not, get educated
because there's a ton
of good shit going on.
They won't, brother.
The same way that Procter &
Gamble was built on television
because they understood it best,
or Amazon was built on Google AdWords
and they poured a
fuckload of money into it
and that's how they
became who they are today.
I mean literally, the
company I think that might be
the biggest company in the world in theory
was built on the back of Google AdWords.
So if they're great, they'll be able
to understand what's next.
I think me as a person will be great
because as soon as I don't
like the ROI of Facebook,
I'll be super thrilled to
have a cartoon version of me
running around all of AR.
Or if I got to be on the moon
or if smoke signals are back,
I'll be on the fucking mountain.
Like, wherever the attention is,
that's where I'm gonna be.
And when I get there first,
it's like real estate.
I'm gonna not only get
to the beachfront first,
I'm gonna build the best hotel.
The thing that is really making me win
is when I get to new places,
I try to bring you value,
not me value.
I made a post on Instagram yesterday
which is like if people gave
a fuck about their audience
as much as they gave
a about their audience
giving them a like, they'd be
in a totally different place.
So they won't, you know?
Now if they're really smart,
they realize they have to build brand,
not work on the math that
they're trading on now.
Everybody eventually,
if they're really great,
will graduate from math to art
and then respec for both.
And so that's how I see it.
Yes sir.
(distant indistinct muttering)
Both.
I always say watch what I'm
doing, not what I'm saying.
If I believe that, my
website wouldn't be updated.
I wouldn't have a text
messaging and messaging bot CRM.
I implore you, if you're
getting value for me,
eventually you're gonna realize
I only have 13 to 27 beliefs
and I'm gonna find 100,000
different ways to say it
until one of the ways at the right moment
is gonna get you to get there.
The bigger, more interesting
reason to continue to watch me
is what am I doing?
Like why did I build a Twitch studio today
even though, if you do your homework,
I was on justin.tv, I
love when everyone's like
oh Gary you're late,
I'm like motherfucker,
I was playing video games before your dad
thought about your mom, you know?
(audience laughing)
I think you should do both
because what you don't
wanna do is be reliant.
Here's what happens with great platforms.
They start off phenomenal and free,
and they end up very
expensive and not as good.
Got it?
That's the game.
That's why when you hear me yelling,
like I am now about Instagram
influencers and Facebook,
you know that this is the time.
Because I know, back to my opening rant,
even if all of you do it great,
it's not gonna come out of me.
And what I get in return is your email
that I get 50 times a day which is I did
something nice for you and
your life is different.
This is the time.
So I would do both.
But to your point, real
quick, anybody selling shit,
back to supernova, Instagram
selling hasn't even started.
When I think about the
sheer amount of fashion
that is gonna be sold through Instagram
when the shop integration
is real, seamless
and lacks friction, this is why I continue
to buy Facebook stock.
Do you know how much money
Facebook's gonna make
when they take a rack off
the top of every transaction
sold of every fashion
product sold on Instagram?
Ugh.
(audience chuckling)
Money.
- Any other questions?
Hands up?
- Go ahead, Jenny.
- Jenny on the Mashable UK team.
(distant indistinct muttering)
- Actually, this one I
understand pretty well.
Do I wake up in the morning
and have complete control
emotionally and financially
around every single action
I'm about to take?
That's the best.
The best.
Like, I do whatever the
fuck I want everyday,
which means there's another thing,
people wanna look at it one way.
You know what else it means?
It means everything bad that's
happening to you is on you,
which makes you feel in
control, which makes you happy.
So I keep telling
everybody, I love my losses.
They're my Ls.
- The personal responsibility.
- 100%.
When you start realizing
that Brexit or retaining
or fucking Trump or Obama
or Facebook or Instagram
don't control you,
- Shardane.
- Uh-huh,
shit gets real interesting
when you start realizing
the answer to everything is, and what?
And what?
What are you gonna tell me?
You were raped as a kid?
Cool, like it's not cool,
but and what?
Like, because I'll tell you,
I know 10 people that let
it get them to a place
where they committed suicide,
and I'll tell you 10 people who persevered
and it became the strength of their life.
Like, my big thing is if there's
a single person that exists
that looks like you from your circumstance
that has ever been happy and made it,
well then you can, in theory, too.
And I think we really love excuses.
Do you know why I pushed so hard
against your series of
questions when you opened?
If you follow it through,
it's going to give people
excuses to why not.
- But asking those questions
are really important though.
- And good news,
everybody's gonna ask them.
(crosstalk)
No, no, no, no, no.
The bigger responsibility
is to actually understand
that, that's exactly where
everybody's gonna go.
And the bigger question
becomes when are we gonna take
responsibility on ourselves
24/7, 365 for life
because that is a far easier gateway.
Because guess what, I'm
thrilled that you guys
are regulating the Internet
with all this shit.
The Blockchain is coming, now what?
Look, I think look, you
have to know yourself.
I love chaos.
I'd rather do 19 things, you know,
seven of them really well, three
shitty, one magically well.
Like, that's me.
Other people really wanna go
super deep into one thing.
I'm not crippled by the opportunity.
A lot of the themes we're talking about,
where you know it's funny,
I used the word accountability,
I would actually argue that
maybe there's a better word
for the energy that I'm trying to deploy
with all these macro things
that we're trying to figure out.
It's about self-awareness.
What's my advice?
If you're like me and
need all sorts of stimuli
to like live your life,
it's probably a good idea
to try to challenge them all like I do.
If you're somebody who loves
to get like really deep,
go fucking destroy it on LinkedIn
and don't think about anything else.
Everybody thinks there's
something that fits all,
that's just not true.
It's the thing that fits you.
And the big fear that I have,
the biggest fear I have,
which is why I've been very
diligent about countering my own self,
speaking to self-awareness,
is I don't wanna make people like me.
I'm so petrified that people
see me and wanna do me.
He, even in the way he's
asking this question,
has a level of charisma
and showmanship and energy
that I'm like okay, he
probably can do the vlog thing.
Like kids, like nerdy,
nerdy, nerdy introverted,
introverted, awkward, barely
can even look at me kids
come up to me and they're like,
I'm gonna start a vlog.
I'm like oh fuck.
(audience laughing)
Like, you have to deploy self-awareness.
There is so many ways to win this game.
To your point, maybe you love math.
So you should be more DR oriented.
Maybe you love art, you should fall deeply
in love with Facebook long-form video
because you're one video away
from everything changing.
So I think it's about
self-awareness, brother.
And I would also say, a lot
of people aren't self-aware
so my big thing is, it
goes back to patience.
I don't know, try both!
Good, 2019 and 20 is where you go crazy
and try to be great at everything.
And 2021 is the year that
you decide after that,
whichever one you like the best,
you're gonna discipline
and go down on one.
And we ebb and flow, there you
are DRock, we ebb and flow.
I think we suck suck
right now on Facebook.
15 months ago, we were destroying it.
And I don't judge myself,
like when something's like,
as long as something's working
and it's a net positive,
heck, if nothing's working,
it's kind of interesting to me
because I'm like oh fuck, like,
so I would say that for two years,
my podcast was a piece of
shit then I refigured it,
came up with the audio
experience instead of AskGaryVee
and it went, right?
Instagram was, I wasn't doing my thing
then I decided to get serious
and it started becoming a thing.
YouTube this, (speaking gibberish) got it?
(distant indistinct muttering)
And you have to know
why you're doing things.
Let me explain.
DRock is devastated that
our YouTube isn't better.
(audience chuckling)
You know, DailyVee has probably
declined in viewership,
not grown in the last year.
I'm pumped because the singular
reason I'm doing DailyVee
is to put all this shit on the record.
- Hmmm, (mumbles) archive.
- Do you know how fun this
video is to watch in 29 years?
Do you know how fun it
is for me to call her
and be like yeah, you were
super right about this.
How about me on that one?
(speaking gibberish)
(crosstalk)
But you know what I mean?
Like look, after living what
I lived from 95 to 2007,
I was like fuck, I was
right about a lot of shit.
And also, a lot of cool things
like do you know how
cool it would have been
to have the video of
me speaking to Facebook
back in the day when the
whole company was 300 people?
That's just fun for my kids,
that's just fun for me.
Like, you know how people
like looking at pictures?
How about having 38
minutes of your every day
of your every day?
There's a lot of other
reasons to do a vlog
that have nothing to do with more visitors
to our businesses.
Your great, great grandkids
are gonna watch it
and they'll be like, oh I have his nose.
Like, it's fucking cool,
like this is special.
- You'll probably need some kind of AI
to process like big data just to get
all of the good bits though,
there's a lot of noise in there as well.
(audience chuckling)
- Of course! But guess what,
if it's your grandmother,
you want that noise.
Got it?
Like for you, like if
I told you right now,
hey weird, I've got a
vlog of your grandmother
when she was from 20 to 30, every minute,
you'd watch every fucking second.
I may not watch every
second of your grandma,
but you are, right?
And so you do certain things
for different reasons.
I've got a whole 'nother thing.
I put my IP, me as a human,
into a trust with no value
attached to it for my kids.
I think it's gonna be the
biggest financial thing
I leave them.
I believe that in 53 years,
there's somebody actually
sitting in that couch right now
during this exact session,
feels like they're here
right now with us sitting right there
with the advancement of VR and
they paid my family's trust
800 bucks to be sitting there.
- What you're actually talking
about is there's a process,
(audience chuckling)
a serious point here,
I made a documentary
about big data in 2016,
and one of the people I interviewed
was this scientist who's
basically been recording himself
every two seconds for the past 15 years
and its called life vlogging,
and his reason for doing
that is he can then call up,
say like, what was that wine I had
on that holiday in Sicily,
and he's got this screen,
and the reason that they're
creating all of these memories
is so that they can eventually
use them for human beings,
if we're living much longer
and for example I have Alzheimer's,
it can be a way of actually
trying to reconfigure
your brain so that you can
actually tap into those memories.
So there's so much potential
of where this could go.
- Every word that I've
spoken on every video
of every one of these vlogs
for the last three years,
transcribed and searchable.
You wanna know what my
thoughts on Snapchat have been
for the last four and
a half years straight?
Here you go.
(clicks tongue)
- Yeah, life blogging.
- And people think of it as like
being a charlatan or self-absorbed,
like people are short-term thinkers.
I'm playing chess out here
and I think people are playing checkers.
Yes, yes.
- [James] I'm James,
Gary, nice to meet you.
I'm marketing director
of a fostering agency.
I've (mumbles) for nine years in business
and fashion, events.
I got an opportunity in November
to join the fostering world,
looked at the industry, knew
I was gonna revolutionize it,
got to a point now where the impact
is greater than what I ever imagined.
I recently did an analysis
on our video campaign
compared to our competitors
(mumbles) videos
and we combined, we smashed
them by an additional 25%.
So I've got one of our
directors is visiting next week
and I'm gonna be telling him
that we need to build a
team to capitalize on that.
So what advice would you suggest
in terms of building that team?
You go with experience over youth, or--
- Both, mash too.
- (crosstalk) So a mix of both?
- You know how in fashion a decade ago
it became obvious that it was gonna be
about high, low, right?
Like especially in the women's sector,
I thought it was so
interesting to watch like,
it was cool to have a
$5,000 purse and $3 sandals
and $9 top and $300 jeans,
and I thought that was so great
and I think that's now actually how
society itself is, period.
That's how I think about production.
I think we're learning at Vayner.
We think about this, we're
starting to get our foot, foot,
our hands around, maybe probably feet too,
around this high low.
I think you get a producer who
has 16 years of experience,
she could be a badass
and can help you a ton.
But you get somebody who
knows how to film on a camera
or their phone and they're
22 and they can afford
to like really do it for less clearly
than somebody who's been
doing it for 16 years,
I'm very hot on production
capabilities being high low.
Because the problem with
high is not only cost
but it's also entitlement.
The reason I'm calling my
next sneaker Clouds and Dirt
is my magic is being in the dirt.
I don't think I'm too fancy
to community manage to you
or answer your DM or post my own copy
or do any of this shit.
And the second you give up the
dirt, you become vulnerable.
- [James] So help in balancing that.
- Go ahead.
(distant indistinct muttering)
I deploy a motion, good
emotion, to everybody else,
but I don't, look, I think for me,
I still believe in no motion meaning
I do not make decisions out of defense.
And I think when you're
going with emotion,
you know, I have empathy and compassion
and I think it's super
important to bring more.
The ultimate leverage in
life is giving somebody more
than you're asking for in return.
So I like doing that.
I just wanna give, I did
it for my own parents.
Like real quick, you know I
always say like if you're smart
you can really figure out?
The fact that I needed it,
forget about being a good boy,
I needed for me because I
was so grateful for my folks
to go into their business
and completely change
the course of their game,
not for me, for them,
I needed to settle the
score with my parents.
Of course I wanna bring value
to my community, got it?
Look, I think when you have a business,
now look, you're an employee, right?
You have a different game.
But number one, you have to
understand it's all on you.
If something bad happened, it's on you.
If a client fires us, well I
could have done a better job,
I could have staffed it better,
I could have checked in
more on the decision maker.
A million things could have,
and so I don't worry
about what outside forces
are doing to me because
when you start dwelling,
you start looking in the wrong direction.
So I try to be like, you know,
I mean, you get upset,
you have to understand
the difference between a
macro at a micro analyzation
of caring and got it?
- Like, how much vulnerability,
I guess, do you show?
That's kind of what your
point in that, isn't it?
Like, there's a fine line
between being vulnerable
in a work place and
kind of like authentic,
but then also being strong
and showing leadership.
- I think you have to
know your environment.
Being vulnerable at
VaynerMedia is super easy.
Being vulnerable at some
other company, not as easy.
I mean, you gotta know
the room you're in, right?
The context.
Ultimately, this got
brought up again earlier
and I'm really happy it did,
I love when people like
you're confusing me or this,
or you're conflicting yourself.
I'm like of course.
Because in the most basic statements,
I think of all of it like a bridge.
There are so many forces pulling
and in that is the strength.
Like, I'm awfully emotional
and I'm completely unemotional.
Now go decipher that in
a fucking Instagram post.
(audience laughing)
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, it's the context to
all of this that matters.
Here's what I would say.
And look, I'm probably
reacting to my father.
My father mainly made emotional decisions.
At the heat of his upsetness
was when he decided
to make a business move.
For me, of course I get upset.
Listen bro, you know this.
Like, there's 88,000 things
wrong with VaynerMedia.
- Only 88,000?
You counted.
- Probably more, you know?
Like, I could sit and dwell on that
or I could think about the
many things that are going well
and continue the process of trying to fix
the ones that aren't going well.
So for me, this is just
super fucking binary.
The whole theme, you know,
for the people at home
that are gonna watch us on YouTube,
if you really take a step back
after a couple glasses of wine,
if you watch today's
talk where this talk was,
and this is, thank you so much
and the energy of you guys,
this is a very clear
mapping of where I'm at,
which is this shit's binary.
Either you see a good or you see a bad.
Either you see offense or you see defense.
This is one or zero.
It's truly that, and I
think everything we're doing
overcomplicates it, overcomplicates it,
and you're not looking at the actual game.
And so yeah, both.
But I never make decisions
out of a place of weakness,
which is usually when
you're most emotional
about something that you
don't control, right?
By virtue, client services suck
because you're not in control
because one client can fire you
and really change the
trajectory of a business,
which is why Vayner's
been always so healthy
because I never let any client get too big
of a percentage of our business
because I don't wanna be
at the mercy of anything
or anybody ever, ever.
- I did mention voice AI earlier
and I feel it would be
remiss of me not to ask you
a question about voice AI,
and I'm just thinking about
all of the people in the room.
Gary earlier tweeted
or retweeted an article
that I have written about
our conversation of voice AI
so we can get a lot more on that,
we won't get into great depth,
but this is something you're
extremely excited about.
And you know, as someone who's working
in the publishing world,
I'm wondering yeah,
voice AI is a thing that everyone
wants, grabbing unto now.
Should we be innovating?
I can't find a business case for it now.
You know, what would you say to people
who are really interested in this
but aren't sure about whether
they should invest the money
or the time or the effort in it,
because it's kind of a road
map that hasn't really been
laid out just yet.
- Go read the history of the
iPhone in the first year.
- So you're saying it's gonna
be as big as the iPhone?
- Yes.
- Okay, we'll leave it at that.
(audience laughing)
Finally, do you wanna
take up the challenge
in the arm wrestle?
- Yeah.
- Let's do it.
(audience laughing)
Put it to end.
- Real quick, I wanna
bring you guys some value
on the iPhone, just to like,
back to remember when I said
I gotta add sentences like
cool, mic drop, iPhone,
but let me tell you why.
I wanna remind you, this is the place
where Spotify and Instagram
and Waze and many others
built multi-billion dollar co,
like I'm looking around,
a lot of us were here
when the iPhone came.
- And Uber.
- Right, Uber.
Listen, we could sit here,
I mean every gaming company, Rovio.
I mean, like multi-billion
dollar companies
built exclusively through
being something on top of this.
I believe that the voice devices,
in whatever manifestation,
there'll be speakers now,
later they'll be in our
walls or whatever it may be,
that the apps built on top of them
will be some of the biggest
companies in the world
because you will use those apps
because of the lack of friction,
the same reason you,
the reason you use Waze
is because it's better
than the gremlin shit
we used to have in our car,
which was better than the fucking map
that we used to pull out.
It's better.
And voice is gonna be better
in the same way that you,
guys, everything goes in circles.
You now text a lot where you used to talk.
Now voice is gonna come
along and take a lot
of your texting away because
you're gonna be in your office
and you're gonna be like, tell my wife
I'll be home in seven
minutes, and that'll be it.
Not, let me grab my phone,
let me find my wife's contact,
I'll be home in seven minutes.
It's just faster, and
you will choose speed
every day of your life.
- We could do an entire session on voice
so we should probably sign post
for the next Drinking and Thinking.
All right, wait back
Gary, which hand are you?
I'm left handed so--
- Oh fuck, I'm right handed.
(audience laughing)
Let's go leftie.
Fuck, I'm a little scared now.
DRock, if I lose, take it out.
(audience laughing)
(indistinct chattering)
- Okay, let's do this.
See those guns?
- I do see them.
(laughs)
Ready?
Should somebody go one, two, three?
- One, two, three, go!
Oh!
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
You did such a great job.
- No worries.
- Let's clap it up, she was phenomenal!
You're amazing.
(audience cheering)
(indistinct chattering)
The arm wrestling thing
is gonna be so loved!
(funky music)